number five finally here's an article
that escaped my attention a year ago
um but i i just saw it now because
making the rounds again online
telling us of a certain group that i'm
guessing probably with covet has been on
hiatus
so if you're looking to join the group
you'll probably have to wait but
these people exist and they're out there
um it is uh here's what it says from the
inquirer.com it says
twice a month half a dozen men gather in
plymouth meeting
uh in a in a plymouth meeting to help
each other work through past traumas
their chosen method of healing cuddles
it may seem odd but members of the men's
therapeutic
cuddle group say the practice has helped
them cope with everything from childhood
sexual abuse to the loss of family
members when they were young
the two-year-old group draws men from
various
backgrounds a 37 year old mormon 57 year
old married father of three
a 60 62 year old retiree there's a range
of sexual orientations
at a time when traditional ideas of
manhood are facing scrutiny
in such terms as toxic masculinity or
becoming widely known
the group aims to provide new ways for
men to express themselves
unlike professional cuddling services
which is a thing professional cuddling
services
the group charges no fees that's good
and members are not required to
undergo training
can you get a degree in cuddling i bet
you can i bet you can
although the meetups are not open to the
public the group held a demonstration
for the enquirer
at the beginning of the session everyone
agreed not to engage in sexual touch
and to ask for consent before each
action
they gathered in a huddle and breathed
meditatively
the cuddling started with men pairing up
to do the motorcycle hold
this sounds horrifying already uh in
what in which one man sits with his back
against another man's chest
as if they were riding together on a
motorcycle
some massage their parent their their
partner's
shoulders or or hands while others
stroked the other person's beard
many clothes stroke the other person's
beard
many closed their eyes as the room fell
into silence after 15 minutes they
switched to a new partner
for the second half of the session the
men cuddled as one large group
in what they call a puppy pile
men lay with their heads in each other's
laps chatted and joked
oh my god in heaven god help us
god help us all and you know you know
you know all these dudes use emojis
okay so i you know i'm right about this
i i don't know do i need to spell out
the issues here do i need to
what you find here actually illustrated
in in very disturbing and graphic detail
um is this fundamental misunderstanding
on the left
about masculinity and femininity and
they think oh well you know
we just have to tear down the artifice
of masculinity we have to
the artificial construct of masculinity
we have to tear down because that's the
only reason
that dudes don't cuddle they really want
to deep down but they don't because
they're worried that society will frown
on
you know frown upon it no no see that's
not it yes
society will frown upon it and should
but that's not the point society could
give
the puppy pile filled with dudes a big
thumbs up
and i still would decline because the
whole reason we don't associate men with
cuddling
isn't that men don't cuddle because we
don't associate them with it
it's that we it it's that we we don't
associate them with it
because they don't do it okay for the
most part there is something deeply
ingrained
naturally ingrained in our net in our
masculine nature that makes us far less
touchy-feely than women
there are exceptions sometimes those
exceptions take horrific form like this
but
you're never going to build a society of
cuddling men because
most men don't have that in them thank
god
so we will continue to confine ourselves
to handshakes fist bumps
um the off awkward sort of half
handshake half hug thing or my specialty
is the series
of aborted greetings that you that you
get when
you know there's two guys that don't
know how the other likes to greet
and so you get the kind of going in for
the handshake the
kind of handshake and then it looks like
they're going for a hug and then you
back up and then it's just kind of
and you're you know it's like you're a
video game sort of like
freezing um that's my move
my move in other words is to make
everyone feel a lot less comfortable
than they did before i entered the room
but
they're still a lot more comfortable
than they would be if i walked into the
room
and asked who's up for a good cuddle uh
i
i think that would make it far less
comfortable i think well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt walsh
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content